okay hi everyone welcome back to cs224n
so today is a pretty key lecture where
we get through a number of important
topics for neural networks especially as
applied to natural language processing
so right at the end of last time i
started into current neural networks so
we'll talk in detail more about current
neural networks in the first part of the
class and
we'd emphasize language models um but
then also getting a bit beyond that and
then look at more advanced kinds of
recurrent neural networks towards the
end part of the class
um i just wanted to sort of say a word
before getting underway about the final
project so hopefully by now you've
started looking at assignment three
which is the middle of the five
assignments for the first half of the
course and then in the second half of
the course most of your effort goes into
a final project
so next week the thursday lecture is
going to be about final projects and
choosing the final project and tips for
final projects etc so it's fine to delay
thinking about
final projects until next week if you
want but you shouldn't delay it too so
long because we do want you to get
underway with what topic you're going to
do for your final project if you are
thinking about final projects you can
find some info um on the website but
note that the info that's there at the
moment is still last year's information
and it will be being updated over the
coming week
we'll also talk about project mentors if
you've got ideas of people who on your
own you can line up as a mentor that now
be a good time to ask them about it and
we'll sort of talk about what the
alternatives are
okay so um
last lecture
i introduced the idea of language models
so probabilistic models that predict the
probability of next words after a word
sequence and then we looked at engram
language models and started into a
current neural network models so today
we're going to talk more about the
simple rnns we saw before talking about
training rnn's and uses of rnns but then
we'll also look into the problems
that occur with rnns and how we might
fix them these will motivate a more
sophisticated rn architecture called
lstms and we'll talk about other more
complex rnn options bi-directional rnns
and multi-layer rnns
then next tuesday
we're essentially going to
ex further exploit and build on the rnn
based architectures that we've been
looking at to discuss how to build a
newer machine translation system with
the sequence to sequence and model with
attention and effectively as that model
um is what you'll use in assignment for
but it also means that you'll be using
all of the stuff that we're talking
about today
okay so if you remember from last time
this was the idea of a simple recurrent
neural network language model so we had
a sequence of words as our context for
which we've looked up word embeddings
and then their current neural network
model ran this recurrent layer
where at each point we have a previous
hidden state which can just be zero at
the beginning of a sequence
and you have feeding it in
to the next hidden state the previous
hidden state and encoding
and transform the coding of a word
using this recurrent neural network
equation that i have on the left that's
very central and based on that you
compute a new hidden representation for
the next time step
and you can repeat that along for
successive time steps
now we also
usually want our recurrent neural
networks to produce outputs so
i only show it at the end here but at
each time step we're then also going to
generate an output and so to do that
we're feeding the hidden layer into a
soft max layer so we're doing another
matrix multiply add on a bias put it
through the soft max equation and that
will then gives the probability
distribution over words and we can use
that to predict how likely it is that
different words are going to occur after
the students open there
okay so i didn't i'd introduced that
model but i hadn't really gone through
the specifics of how we um train this
model how we use it and evaluate it so
let me um go through this now
so here's how we train an rnn language
model we get a big corpus of text just a
lot of text and so we can regard that as
just a long sequence of words x1 to xt
and what we're going to do is feed it
into the rnnlm
so for each posit we're going to take
prefixes of that sequence and based on
each prefix we're going to want to
predict
the probability distribution for the
word that comes next
and then we're going to train our model
by assessing how good a job we do about
that and so the loss function we use is
the loss function normally
referred to as cross-entropy loss in the
literature which is this negative log
likelihood lasts so we are going to
predict
some word to come next well we we have a
probability distribution over
predictions of what word comes next and
actually there was an actual next word
in the text and so we say well what
probability did you give to that word
and maybe we gave it a probability
estimate of 0.01 well it would have been
great if we'd given a probability
estimate of almost one because that
meant we've almost certain that what did
come next
in our model and so we'll
take a loss to the extent that we're
giving the actual next word a predicted
probability of less than one
to then get an idea of how well we're
doing over the
entire um corpus we work out that loss
at each position and then we work out
the average loss of the entire training
set
so let's just go through that again
more graphically in the next
couple of slides so down the bottom
here's our corpus of text
we're running it through
our simple recurrent neural network and
at each position
we've predicting a probability
distribution over words
we then
say
well actually
at each position we know what word is
actually next so when we're at time step
one
the actual next word is students because
we can see it just to the right of us
here and we say what probability
estimate did you give to students and to
the extent that it's not high it's not
one we take a loss and then we go on to
the time step two and we say well at
time step two you predicted probability
distribution over words
the actual next word is opened so to the
extent that you haven't given high
probability to open you take a loss and
then that repeats for in time step three
we're hoping the model predict there at
time step four we're hoping the model
will predict exams and then to work out
our overall loss
we're then
um averaging our per time step loss
so
in a way this is a pretty obvious thing
to do but note that there is a little
subtlety here and in particular this
algorithm is referred to in the
literature as teacher forcing
and so what does that mean well you know
you can imagine what you can do with a
recurrent neural network is say
okay just start generating maybe i'll
give you a hint as to where to start
i'll say the sentence starts the
students and then
let it run and see what it generates
coming next um it might start saying
the students have been locked out of the
classroom or whatever it is right um and
that we could say is well that's not
very close to what the actual text says
and somehow we want to learn from that
and if you go in that direction
there's a space of things you can do
that leads into more complex algorithms
such as reinforcement learning um but
from the perspective of training these
neural models that's unduly complex and
unnecessary so we have this very simple
way of doing things which is what we do
is just predict one time step forward so
we say we know that the prefix is the
predict a probability distribution over
the next word it's good to the extent
that you give probability master opened
okay now the prefix is the student's
opened predict
a probability distribution over the next
word it's good to the extent that you
give probability master there and so
effectively at each step we're resetting
to what was actually in the corpus so
you know it's possible after the
students opened the model thinks that by
far the most probable thing to come next
is ah or thus say i mean we don't
actually use what the model suggested we
penalize the model for not having
suggested there but then we just go with
what's actually in the corpus and ask it
to predict again
this is just a little
side thing but it's an important part to
know
if you're actually training your own
neural language model i sort of
presented as one huge
corpus that we chug through but in
practice we don't chug through a whole
corpus one step at a time what we do is
we cut the whole corpus into shorter
pieces which might commonly be sentences
or documents or sometimes they're
literally just pieces that are chopped
right so you'll recall that stochastic
gradient scent allows us to compute a
loss and gradients from a small chunk of
data and update so what we do is we take
these small pieces compute gradients
from those and update weights and repeat
and in particular
we get a lot more speed and efficiency
and training if we aren't actually
doing an update for just one sentence at
a time but actually a batch of sentences
so typically what we'll actually do is
we'll feed to the model 32 sentences say
of a similar length at the same time
compute gradients for them um update
weights and then get another batch of
sentences to train on
um how do we train i haven't sort of
gone through the details of this i mean
in one sense the answer is just like we
talked about in lecture three um we use
back propagation to get gradients and
update parameters um but let's take at
least a minute to go through the
differences and subtleties of the
current neural network case um and the
central thing that's a bit you know as
before we're going to take our loss and
we're going to back propagate it to all
of the parameters of the network
everything from word embeddings to
biases etc but the central bit that's a
little bit different and is more
complicated is
that we have this wh matrix that runs
along the sequence that we keep on
applying to update um our hidden state
so what's the derivative of jt of theta
with respect to the repeated weight
matrix wh
and well the the answer to that is that
what we do is we
look at it in each position
and work out what the partials are of gt
with respect to wh in position one or
position two position three position
four etcetera right along the sequence
and we just sum up all of those partials
and that gives us a partial for jt with
respect to wh overall
um so
the answer for a current neural networks
is the gradient with respect to a
repeated weight in our current network
is the sum of the gradient with respect
to each time it appears
um
and let me just then
go through a little why that is the case
but before i do that let me just
note one gotcha i mean
it's just not the case that this means
it equals t times the partial of jt with
respect to wh because we're using wh
here here here here here through the
sequence and for each of the places we
use it there's a different upstream
gradient that's being fed into it so
each of the values in this sum will be
completely different from each other
well
why we get this answer is essentially a
consequence of what we talked about in
the third lecture
so to take the simplest case of that
right that if you have a multi-variable
function f of x y
and you have two
single variable functions x of t and y
of t
which are fed one input t
well then the um simple
um version of working out the derivative
derivative of this function is you take
the derivative down one path and you
take the derivative down the other path
and so in the slides in
lecture three that was what was
summarized on a couple of slides by the
slogan gradient sum at outward branches
so t has outward branches and so you
take gradient here on the left gradient
on the right and you sum them together
and so really what's happening with the
recurrent neural network is just
many pieces generalization of this so we
have one wh matrix and we're using it to
keep on updating the hidden state at
time 1 time 2 time 3 right through time
t
and so what we're going to get is that
this has a lot of um outward
branches and we're going to sum
the gradient path at each one of them
but
what is this gradient
path here it's kind of goes down here
and then goes down there but you know
actually the bottom part is that we're
just using wh at each position so we
have the partial of wh used at position
i with respect to the partial of wh
which is just our weight matrix for our
current neural network so that's just
one because you know we're just using
the same matrix everywhere and so we are
just then
summing um
the partials in each position that we
use it
okay um practically what does that mean
in terms of how you compute this um well
if you're doing it by hand um what
happens is you start at the end just
like this general lecture three story
you work out
derivatives
with respect to the hidden layer and
then with respect to wh at the last time
step and so that gives you
one update for wh but then you continue
passing the gradient back to the t minus
one time step and after a couple more
steps of the chain rule you get another
update for wh and you simply sum that
onto your previous update for wh and
then you go to
ht minus 2 you get another update for wh
and you sum that onto your update for wh
and you go back all the way
and you sum up the gradients as you go
um and that gives you a total update um
for wh
um and so there's so two tricks here and
i'll just mention um the two tricks you
have to kind of separately sum the
updates for wh and then once you've
finished apply them all at once you
don't want to actually be changing the
wh matrix as you go because that's then
invalid because um the forward
calculations were done with the constant
wh that you had from the previous
state all through the network
the second trick is well if you're doing
this for sentences you can normally just
go back to the beginning of the sentence
but if you've got very long sequences
this can really slow you down if you're
having to sort of run this algorithm
back for a huge amount of time
so something people commonly do is
what's called truncated back propagation
through time where you choose some
constant say 20 and you say well i'm
just going to run this back propagation
for 20 time steps sum those 20 gradients
and then i'm just done that's what i'll
update the wh matrix with
and that works just fine
okay so now given a corpus
we can train
a
simple rnn and so that's good progress
but
this is a model that can also generate
text in general so how do we generate
text well just like in our engram
language model we're going to generate
text by repeated sampling so we're going
to start off with an initial state
and
um yeah this slide is imperfect um
so the initial state for the hidden
state um
is is normally just taken as a zero
vector and well then we need to have
something for a first input and on this
slide the first input is shown as the
first word my and if you want to feed a
starting point you could feed my but a
lot of the time you'd like to generate a
sentence from nothing and if you want to
do that what's conventional is to
additionally have a beginning of
sequence token which is a special token
so you'll feed in the beginning of
sequence token in at the beginning as
the first token it has an embedding and
then you use the
rnn update and then you generate using
the softmax and next word and
um well you generate a probability of
probability distribution over next words
and then at that point you sample from
that and it chooses some word like
favorite and so then the trick is for
doing generation that you take this word
that you sampled and you copy it back
down to the input and then you feed it
in as an import next step if you are an
n
sample from the softmax get another word
and just keep repeating this over and
over again and you start generating the
text
and how you end is as well as having a
beginning of sequence
um special symbol you usually have an
end of sequence special symbol and at
some point um the recurrent neural
network will generate the end of
um sequence symbol and then you say okay
i'm done i'm finished generating text
so before going on for the
more of the
difficult content of the lecture we can
just have a little bit of fun with this
and try
training up and generating text with our
current neural network model so you can
generate you can train an rnn on any
kind of text and so that means one of
the fun things that you can do is
generate text
in different styles based on what you
could train it from
so here
harry potter is a there is a fair amount
of a corpus of text so you can train rnn
lm on the harry potter books and then
say dolph and generate some text and
it'll generate text like this sorry how
harry shouted panicking i'll leave those
brooms in london are they
no idea said nearly headless nick
casting low close by cedric carrying the
last bit of treacle charms from harry's
shoulder and to answer him the common
room pushed upon it four arms held a
shining knob from when the spider hadn't
felt it seemed he reached the teams too
um well so on the one hand that's still
kind of a bit incoherent as a story on
the other hand it sort of sounds like
harry potter and certainly the kind of
you know vocabulary and constructions in
users and i think you'd agree that you
know even though it gets sort of
incoherent it's sort of more coherent
than what we got from an engram language
model um when i showed a generation in
the last
lecture
you can choose a very different style of
text
so you could instead
train the model on a bunch of cookbooks
and if you do that you can then say
generate
based on what you've learned about
cookbooks
and it'll just generate a recipe so
here's a recipe
chocolate ranch bbq
categories yield six servings
two tablespoons of parmesan cheese
chopped and one cup of coconut milk
three eggs beaten
place each pasta over layers of lumps
shaped mixture into the moderate oven
and simmer until firm serve hot embodied
fresh mustard orange and cheese
combine the cheese and salt together
the dough in a large skillet add the
ingredients and stir in the chocolate
and pepper
so you know um this recipe makes um no
sense and it's sufficiently um
incoherent there's actually even no
danger that you'll try cooking this at
home um but you know something that's
interesting is although you know there's
really just
isn't a recipe and the things that are
done in the instructions have no
relation um to the ingredients the the
thing that's interesting that it has
learned is this recurrent neural network
model is that it's really mastered the
overall structure of a recipe it knows
the recipe has a title it often tells
you about how many people it serves it
lists the ingredients and then it has
instructions um to make it so that's
sort of fairly impressive in some sense
for high level text structuring
um so the one other thing i wanted to
mention was
when i say you can train an rnn language
model in any kind of text the other
difference from where we were in in gram
language models was on engram language
models that just meant counting engrams
and meant it took um
two minutes or even on a large corpus
with any modern computer training your
rnn lm actually can then be a time
intensive activity and you can spend
hours doing that as you might find next
week when you're training
machine translation models
okay
how do we decide if our models are good
or not
um
so the standard evaluation metric for
language models is what's called
perplexity
and what perplexity is is
um
kind of like when you were
training your model you use teacher
forcing
over a piece of text that's a different
piece of test text which isn't text that
was in the training data and you say
well given a sequence of t words
what probability do you give to the
actual t plus one word and you
repeat that at each position
and then you take the inverse of that
probability and raise it to the
one on t for the length of your test
text sample
and that number is the perplexity so
it's a geometric mean of the inverse
probabilities
now um after that explanation perhaps an
easier way to think of it is that the
perplexity
is simply
the cross entropy loss that i introduced
before exponentiated
so
but you know it's now the other way
around
so low perplexity um is better so
there's actually an interesting story
about these perplexities um so a famous
figure in the development of
probabilistic and machine learning
approaches to natural language
processing is fred gellanek who died a
few years ago
and he was trying to
interest people in the idea of using
probability models and machine learning
um for natural language processing at a
time i this is the 1970s and early 1980s
when nearly everyone in the field of ai
was still in the thrall of logic based
models and blackboard architectures and
things like that for artificial
intelligence systems and so fred
gellarnek was actually an information
theorist by background um and who
then got interested in working with
speech and then language data
so at that time the stuff that's this
sort of um exponential or using
cross-entropy losses was completely
bread and butter to fred jelinek but
he'd found that no one in ai could
understand the bottom half of the slide
and so he wanted to come up with
something simple that ai people at that
time could understand and perplexity has
a kind of a simple
interpretation you can tell people so if
you get a perplexity of
53 that means how uncertain you are
of the next word is equivalent to the
uncertainty of that you're tossing a
53-sided dice and it's coming up as a
one right so um that was kind of an easy
simple metric and so he introduced um
that idea
um but you know i guess things stick and
to this day um everyone evaluates their
language models by providing perplexity
numbers and so here are some perplexity
numbers
so traditional engram language models
commonly had perplexities over a hundred
but if you made them really big and
really careful you carefully you could
get them down into a number like 67 as
people started to build more advanced
recurrent neural networks especially as
they moved beyond the kind of simple
rnn's which is all i've shown you so far
which one of is in the second site line
of the slide into
lstms which i talk about later in this
course that people started producing
much better perplexities and here we're
getting perplexities down to 30 and this
is results actually from a few years ago
so nowadays people get perplexities of
even lower than 30. um you have to be
realistic in what you can expect right
because if you're just generally
generating a text some words are almost
determined um so you know if it's
something like um
you know zoom gave the man a napkin he
said thank
you know basically a hundred percent you
should be able to say the word that
comes next is you um and so that you can
predict really well but um you know if
it's a lot of other sentences like um he
looked out the window and saw uh
something right no probability in the
model model in the world can give a very
good estimate of what's actually going
to be coming next to that point and so
that gives us the sort of residual
uncertainty that leads to perplexities
that are on average might be around 20
or something
okay
um
so we've talked a lot about language
models now why should we care about
language modeling you know well there's
sort of an
intellectual scientific answer that says
this is a benchmark task right if we
what we want to do is build machine
learning models of language and our
ability to predict what word will come
next in the context that shows how well
we understand both the structure of
language and the structure of the human
world that
language talks about um but there's a
much more practical answer than that um
which is you know language models are
really the secret tool of natural
language processing so if you're
talking to any nlp person and you've got
almost any task
it's quite likely they'll say oh i
bet we could use a language model for
that and so language models are sort of
used as a not the whole solution but a
part of almost any task any task that
involves generating or estimating the
probability of text so you can use it
for predictive typing speech recognition
grammar correction identifying authors
machine translation summarization
dialogue just about anything you do with
natural language involves language
models and we'll see examples of that
in following classes including next
tuesday where we're using language
models for machine translation
okay so a language model
is just a system that predicts the next
word um a recurrent neural network is a
family of neural networks which can
take sequential input of any length
they reuse the same weights to generate
a hidden state and optionally but
commonly an output on each step
note that these two things are different
so
we've talked about two ways that you
could build language models but one of
them is rnn's being a great way but rnns
can also be used for a lot of other
things so let me just quickly preview a
few of the things you can do with rnns
so there are lots of tasks that people
want to do in nlp which are referred to
as sequence tagging tasks where we'd
like to take words of text and do some
kind of classification along the
sequence so one simple common one is to
give words parts of speech that is a
determiner startled as an adjective cat
is a noun knocked as a verb um and well
you can do this straightforwardly by
using a current neural network as a
sequential classifier where it's now
going to generate parts of speech rather
than the next word
you can use a recurrent neural network
the sentiment classification
well
this time we don't actually want to
generate um and outputted each word
necessarily but we want to know what the
overall sentiment looks like so somehow
we want to get out a sentence encoding
that we can perhaps put through another
neural network layer to judge whether
the sentence is positive
or negative well the simplest way to do
that is to think well
after
i've
run my
lstm
through the whole sentence actually this
final hidden state it's encoded the
whole sentence because remember i
updated that hidden state based on each
previous word and so you could say that
this is the whole meaning of the
sentence so let's just say that is the
sentence encoding
and then put an extra
classifier layer on that with something
like a softmax classifier um that method
has been used and it actually works
reasonably well and if you sort of train
this model end to end well it's actually
then motivated to preserve sentiment
information in the hidden state of the
current neural network because that will
allow it to better predict the sentiment
of the whole sentence
which is the final task and hence loss
function that we're giving the network
but it turns out that you can commonly
do better than that by actually doing
things like feeding all hidden states
into the sentence and coding perhaps by
making the sentence encoding an
element-wise max or an element
wise mean of all the hidden states
because this then more symmetrically
encodes
the hidden state over each time step
another big use of recurrent neural
networks is
what i'll call language encoder
module uses so anytime you have some
text for example here we have a question
of what nationality was beethoven
we'd like to construct some kind of
newer representation of this so one way
to do it is to run
the current neural network over it and
then just like last time
to either take the final hidden state or
take some kind of
function of all the hidden states and
say that's the sentence representation
and we could do the same thing
for the context so for question
answering we're going to build some more
neural net structure
on top of that and we'll learn more
about that in a couple of weeks um when
we have the question answering lecture
but
the key thing is what we built so far we
use to get sentence representation so
it's a language encoder module
so that was the language encoding part
we can also use rnns to decode into
language and that's commonly used in
speech recognition machine translation
summarization so if we have a speech
recognizer the input is an audio signal
and what we want to do is decode that
into language well what we could do is
use some function of the input which is
probably itself going to be neural net
as the
initial
hidden state of
our rnn lm
and then we say start generating text
based on that and so it should then
we generate word at a time by the method
that we just looked at
we turn the speech into text
so this is an example of a conditional
language model because we're now
generating text conditioned on the
speech signal and a lot of the time you
can do
interesting more advanced things with
recurrent neural networks by building
conditional language models another
place you can use conditional language
models is for text classification tasks
and including sentiment classification
so if you can condition
your
language model based on a kind of
sentiment you can build a kind of
classifier for that and another use that
we'll see a lot of next class is for
machine translation
okay
so that's the end of the intro
to
doing things with
recurrent neural networks and language
models now i want to move on and tell
you about the fact that everything is
not perfect and these recurrent neural
networks tend to have a couple of
problems
and we'll talk about those and then in
part that'll then motivate coming up
with a more advanced recurrent neural
network architecture
so the first problem to be mentioned is
the idea of what's called vanishing
gradients
and what does that mean well at the end
of our sequence we have some overall
loss that we're calculating and well
what we want to do is back propagate
that loss
and we want to back propagate it right
along the sequence and so we're working
out the partials of j4
with respect to the hidden state at time
one and when we have a longer sequence
we'll be working out the partials of j20
with respect to the hidden state at time
one and
how do we do that well how we do it is
by composition and the chain rule we've
got a big long chain roll along the
whole sequence
um
well if we're doing that
you know we're multiplying a ton of
things together
and so the danger of what tends to
happen
is that as we do these
multiplications a lot of time
these partials
successive hidden states becomes small
and so what happens is as we go along
the gradient gets smaller and smaller
and smaller and starts to peter out
and to the extent that it peters out
well then we've kind of got no upstream
gradient and therefore we won't be
changing the parameters at all and that
turns out to be pretty problematic
um
so the next couple of slides sort of um
say a little bit about the why and how
this happens
what's presented here is a kind of only
semi
formal
wave your hands at the kind of problems
that you might expect um if you really
want to sort of get into all the details
of this um you should look at the couple
of papers that are mentioned in small
print at the bottom of the slide but at
any rate if you remember that this is
our basic um recurrent neural network
equation well let's consider an easy
case suppose we sort of get rid of our
non-linearity and just assume that it's
an identity function
okay so then when we're working out the
partials of the hidden state with
respect to the previous hidden state
we can work those out in the usual way
according to the chain rule
and then if
sigma
is
simply the identity function
well then everything gets really easy
for us so
only the
the sigma just goes away and only the
first term
involves um h at time t minus one so the
later terms go away and so um our
gradient ends up as wh
well that's doing it for just one time
step what happens when you want to work
out these partials a number of times
steps away so
we want to work it out the partial of
time step i with respect to j
um
well what we end up with is a product of
the partials of successive time steps
and while each of those
is coming out as wh and so we end up
getting wh raised to the elf power
and well our potential problem is that
if wh is small in some sense then this
term gets exponentially problematic i it
becomes vanishingly small as our
sequence length becomes long
well what can we mean by small well a
matrix is small
if its eigenvalues are all less than one
so we can rewrite what's happening with
this success of multiplication using
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
um and i should say that all i can
vector values less than one is a
sufficient but not necessary condition
for what i'm about to say um right so we
can rewrite
things using the eigenvectors as a basis
and if we do that
we end up getting
the
eigenvalues being raised to the eighth
power and so if all of our eigen values
are less than one if we're taking a
number less than one and then raising it
to the eighth power that's going to
approach zero as the sequence length
grows and so the gradient vanishes
okay now the reality is more complex
than that because actually we always use
a non-linear activation sigma but you
know in principle it's sort of the same
thing um apart from we have to consider
in the effect of the non-linear
activation
okay so why is this a problem that the
gradients disappear
well
suppose we're wanting to look at the
influence of time steps well in the
future
on
the representations we want to have
early in the sentence well
what's happening late in the sentence
just isn't going to be giving much
information about what we should be
storing in the h at time 1 vector
whereas on the other hand the loss at
time step two is going to be giving a
lot of information at what
should be stored in the hidden vector at
time step one so the end result of that
is that what happens is these simple
rnn's are very good at modeling nearby
effects
but they're not good at all at modeling
long-term effects because the gradient
signal from far away is just lost too
much
and therefore the model never
effectively gets to learn
what information from far away it would
be useful to preserve into the future
so let's consider that concretely um for
the example
of language models that we've worked on
so here's a piece of text um when she
tried to print her tickets she found
that the printer was out of toner she
went to the stationery store to buy more
toner it was very overpriced after
installing the toner into the printer
she finally printed her
and well you're all smart human beings i
trust you can all guess what the word
that comes next is it should be tickets
but well the problem is that for the rnn
to start to learn cases like this it
would have to carry through in its
hidden state a memory of the word
tickets for sort of whatever it is about
30 hidden state updates
and well
we'll train on this um example and so
we'll be wanting it to predict tickets
is the next word and so a gradient
update will be sent right back through
the hidden states of the lstm
corresponding to this sentence
and
that should tell the model
it's good to preserve information about
the word tickers because that might be
useful in the future here it was useful
in the future
but the problem is that
the gradient signal will just become far
too weak out over after a bunch of words
and it just never learns that dependency
and so what we find in practice is the
model is just unable to predict similar
long-distance dependencies at test time
i've spent quite a long time on
vanishing gradients and then really
vanishing gradients are the big problem
in practice um with using
recurrent neural networks over long
sequences
but you know i have to do justice to the
fact that you can actually also have the
opposite problem you can also have
exploding gradients
so
if a gradient becomes too big that's
also a problem and it's a problem
because the stochastic gradient
update step becomes too big right so
remember that our parameter update is
based on the product of the learning
rate and the gradient so if your
gradient is huge right you've calculated
oh it's got a lot of slope here this has
a slope of 10 000
then your
parameter update can be arbitrarily
large
and that's potentially problematic that
can cause a bad update where you take a
huge step and you end up at a weird and
bad
parameter configuration so you sort of
think you're coming up with a
to a steep hill to climb and well you
want to be climbing the hill to high
likelihood but actually the gradient is
so sleek steep that you make an enormous
update and then suddenly your parameters
are over in iowa and you've lost your
hill altogether there's also the
practical difficulty that we only have
so much resolution now floating point
numbers
so
if your gradient gets too steep um you
start getting
not a numbers in your calculations which
ruin all your hard training work
um we use a kind of an easy fix to this
which is called gradient clipping
which is we choose some reasonable
number and we say we're just not going
to deal with gradients that are bigger
than this number um a commonly used
number is 20 you know some
thing that's got a range of spread but
not that high you know you can use 10
100 some we're sort of in that range um
and if the norm of the gradient is
greater than that threshold we simply
just scale it down which means
that we then make a smaller gradient
update so we're still moving in exactly
the same
direction but we're taking a smaller
step
so doing this gradient clipping is
important
you know but it's an easy problem to
solve
okay um so the thing that we've still
got left to solve is how to really solve
this problem of vanishing gradients
um
so the problem is yeah these rnns just
can't preserve information over many
time steps
and
one way to think about that intuitively
is at each time step we have a hidden
state
and the hidden state is being completely
changed at each time step and it's being
changed in a multiplicative manner by
multiplying by wh and then putting it
through
um
and non-linearity
like maybe we could make some more
progress
if we could more flexibly
maintain a memory in our recurrent
neural network
which we can
manipulate in a more flexible manner
that allows us to more easily preserve
information
and so this was a
idea that people started thinking about
and actually they started thinking about
it a long time ago
in the late 1990s
[Music]
and huck wright and schmidt hoover came
up with this idea
that got called long short term memory
rnns
as a solution to the problem of
vanishing gradients
i mean so this 1997 paper is the paper
you always see cited for lstms but you
know actually
in terms of what we now understand as an
lstm
it was missing part of it in fact it's
missing what in retrospect has turned
out to be the most important part of
the
modern lstm so really in some sense the
real paper that the modern lstm is due
to is this slightly later paper by gersh
still schmidt hoover and cummins from
2000 um which additionally introduces
the forget gate that i'll explain in a
minute um
yeah so um so this was some very clever
stuff that was introduced and it turned
out later to have an enormous impact um
if i just
diverge from the technical part for one
more moment
that you know for those of you who these
days um think that mastering your
networks is the path to fame and fortune
the funny thing is you know at the time
that this work was done
that just was not true right very few
people were interested in neural
networks and although long short-term
memories have turned out to be one of
the most important successful and
influential ideas in neural networks for
the
following 25 years
really the original authors didn't get
recognition for that so both of them are
now professors at german universities
but hawk writer
moved over into doing bioinformatics
work
to find
um something to do and guess actually is
doing kind of multimedia studies um so
um that's the fates of history um
okay
so what is an lstm so the
a crucial innovation of an lstm is to
say well rather than just having one
hidden vector
in the recurrent model we're going to
build a model with
two
hidden vectors at each time step one of
which is still called the hidden state h
and the other of which is called the
cell state
now you know arguably in retrospect
these were named wrongly because as
you'll see when we look at in more
detail in some sense the cell is more
equivalent to the hidden state of the
simple rnn then vice versa but we're
just going with the names that everybody
uses so both of these are vectors of
length n
um and it's going to be the cell that
stores long-term information
and so we want to have something that's
more like memory so the
meaning like ram and the computer um so
the cell is designed so you can read
from it you can erase parts of it and
you can write new information to the
cell
um and the interesting part of an lstm
is then it's got control structures to
decide how you do that so the selection
of which information to erase write and
read is controlled by probabilistic
gates
so the gates are also vectors of length
n
and on each time step um we work out a
state for the gate vectors so each
element of the gate vectors is a
probability so they can be open
probability one close probability zero
or somewhere in between and their value
will be saying how much do you erase how
much do you write how much do you read
and so these are dynamic gates with a
value that's computed based on the
current context
okay so in this next slide we go through
the equations of an lstm but following
this there are some more graphic slides
which will probably be easier to absorb
right so we again just like before it's
our current neural network we have a
sequence of inputs x and t
and we're going to at each time step
compute a cell state and a hidden state
so how do we do that so firstly we're
going to compute values of the three
gates and so we're computing the gate
values using an equation that's
identical to the equation
for the simple recurrent neural network
but in particular um oops sorry i'll
just just say what the gates are first
so there's a forget gate um which can we
will control what is kept
in the cell at the next time step versus
what is forgotten there's an input gate
which is going to determine which parts
of a calculated new cell content get
written to the cell memory and there's
an output gate which is going to control
what parts of the cell memory are moved
over into the hidden state
and so each of these is using the
logistic function because we want them
to be in each element of this vector a
probability which will say whether to
fully forget partially forget or fully
fully remember
yeah and the equation for each of these
is exactly like the simple r and n
equation but note of course that we've
got different parameters for each one so
we've got a forgetting weight matrix w
with a forgetting bias
and a forgetting
multiplier of the input
okay so then we have the other equations
that really are the mechanics of the
lstm
so we have something that will calculate
a new cell content so this is our
candidate update and so
for calculating the candidate update
we're again essentially using exactly
the same simple rnn equation apart from
now it's usual to use tanh so you get
something that as discussed last time is
balanced around zero
okay so then to actually update things
we use our gates so for our new cell
content what the idea is is that we want
to remember some but probably not all of
what we had in the cell from previous
time steps and we want to
store
some but probably not all of the value
that we've calculated as the new
cell
update and so the way we do that is we
take um the previous cell content and
then we take its hadamard product
with the forget vector
and then we add to it the hadamard
product of the input gate times the
candidate cell update
and then for working out the new hidden
state we then work out which parts of
the cell
to expose in the hidden state and so
after taking a tan h transform of the
cell we then take the hadamard product
with the output gate and that gives us
our hidden representation and as this
hidden representation
that we then
put through a soft soft max layer to
generate um our next output of our lstm
or current neural network
yeah so
um the gates
and the things that they're
put with are vectors of size n and what
we're doing is we're taking each element
of them and multiplying them element
wise
to work out a new vector and then we get
two vectors and that we're adding
together so this um way of doing things
element-wise you sort of don't really
see in standard linear algebra course um
it's referred to as the hadamard product
it's represented by some kind of circle
i mean actually in more modern work it's
been more usual to represent it with
this slightly bigger circle with the dot
at the middle as the hadamard product
symbol
and someday i'll change these slides to
be like that but i was lazy and redoing
the equations but the other notation you
do see quite often is just using the
same little circle that you use for
function composition to represent
hadamard product
okay so all of these things are being
done as vectors of the same length n
and the other thing that you might
notice is that the candidate update and
the forget
import and output gates all have a very
similar form the only difference is
three logistics and one tanh and none of
them depend on each other so all four of
those can be calculated in parallel and
if you want to have an efficient lstm
implementation that's what you do
okay so here's the more graphical
presentation of this so these pictures
come from chris ola and i guess he did
such a nice job at producing pictures
for lstms that almost everyone uses them
these days and so this sort of pulls
apart
the computation graph of an lstm unit so
blowing this up
you've got from the previous time step
both your cell and hidden
recurrent
vectors and so you feed the hidden
vector from the previous time step and
the new input x t into the computation
of the gates which is happening down the
bottom so you compute the forget gate
and then you use the forget gate in a
hadamard product here drawn as a
actually a
time symbol to forget some cell content
you work out the input gate and then
using the input gate and a regular
recurrent neural network like
computation you can compute candidate
new cell content
and so then you add those two together
to get the new cell content which then
heads out as the new cell content at
time t
but then you also
have worked out an output gate and so
then you take the cell content
put it through another non-linearity and
multi hadamard product with the output
gate and that then gives you the new
hidden state
um so this is all kind of complex
but as to understanding why something is
different is happening here the thing to
notice is that the cell state from t
minus 1
is passing right through this to be the
cell state at time t
without very much happening to it so
some of it is being deleted
by the forget gate
and then some new stuff is being written
um to it as a result of
using this candidate new cell content
but the real secret
of the
um
lstm
is that new stuff is just being added to
the cell with an addition right so in
the simple rnn at each successive step
you're doing a multiplication
and that makes it incredibly difficult
to learn to preserve information in the
hidden state over a long period of time
is it's not completely impossible but
it's a very difficult thing to learn
whereas with this new lstm architecture
it's trivial to preserve information the
cell from one time step to the next you
just don't forget it
and it'll carry right through with
perhaps some new stuff added in um to
also remember and so that's the sense in
which
the cell behaves much more like ram in a
conventional computer that is storing
stuff and extra stuff can be stored into
it and other stuff can be deleted from
it as you go along
okay so the lstm architecture makes it
much easier to preserve information from
many time steps
right so in particular
standard practice with lstms is to
initialize the forget gate to a one
vector which it's just so that the
starting point is to say preserve
everything um from previous time steps
and then
it is then learning when it's
appropriate to forget stuff
and in contrast it's very hard to get or
a simple rnn to preserve stuff for a
very long time i mean what does that
actually mean
well you know i've put down some numbers
here i mean
you know how what you get in practice
you know depends on a million things it
depends on the nature of your data and
how much data you have and what
dimensionality your
hidden states are blurry bloody blur but
just to give you some idea of what's
going on is typically if you train a
simple recurrent neural network that its
effect of memory its ability to be able
to use things in the past to condition
the future goes for about seven time
steps you just really can't get it to
remember stuff further back in the past
than that whereas um
for the lstm
it's it's not complete magic it doesn't
work forever but you know it's
effectively able to remember and use
things from much much further back so
typically you find that with an lstm you
can effectively remember and use things
about a hundred times steps back and
that's just enormously more useful for a
lot of the natural language
understanding tasks that
we want to do
and so that was precisely what the lstm
was um designed to do and i mean so in
particular just going back to its name i
quite a few people mispassed its name
the idea of its name was there's a
concept of short-term memory which comes
from psychology and it had been
suggested for simple rnns that the
hidden state of the rnn
could be a model of
human short-term memory and then there
would be something somewhere else that
would deal with human long-term memory
but well people had found that this only
gave you a very short short-term memory
um so what um hock wright and schmidt
uber were interested in was how we could
give um
construct models with long short term
memory and so that then gave us this
name of lstm
um lstms don't guarantee that there are
no vanishing or exploding gradients but
in practice they provide
they they don't tend to explode
nearly the same way again that plus sign
is crucial rather than a multiplication
and so they're a much more effective way
of learning long distance dependencies
okay
so despite the fact that lstms were
developed
around 1997
it was really only in the early 2010s
um that the world woke up to them and
how successful they were so it was
really around 2013 to 2015
that lstms sort of hit the world
achieving state-of-the-art results on
all kinds of problems um one of the
first big demonstrations was for
handwriting recognition um then speech
recognition but then going on to a lot
of um natural language tasks including
machine translation parsing um vision
and language tasks like image captioning
as well of course using them for
language models and around these years
lstms became the dominant approach for
most nlp tasks the easiest way to build
a good strong model was to approach the
problem with an lstm
so now in 2021 actually lstms are
starting to be supplanted or have been
supplanted by other approaches
particularly transformer models um which
we'll get to in the class in a couple of
weeks time
so this is the sort of picture you can
see so for many years there's been a
machine translation conference and sort
of bake off competition called wmt
workshop on machine translation
so if you look at the history of that in
wmt 2014
[Music]
there were zero neural machine
translation systems in the competition
2014 was actually the first year
that the success of
um lstms for machine translation was
proven in a conference paper um but
nothing occurred in this competition um
by 2016
[Music]
everyone had jumped on ls dms is working
great um and lots of people including
the winner of the competition was using
an lstm model um if you then jump ahead
to 2019
um then there's relatively little use of
lstms and the vast majority of people
are now using transformers
so things change quickly in your network
land and i keep on having to rewrite
these lectures
um
so quick further note on vanishing and
exploding gradients is it only a problem
with recurrent neural networks it's not
it's actually a problem that also occurs
anywhere where you have a lot of depth
including feed forward and convolutional
neural networks
as
any time when you've got long sequences
of
chain rules which give you
multiplications the gradient can become
vanishingly small as it back propagates
um and so
generally sort of lower layers are
learned very slowly and are hard to
train so there's been a lot of effort in
other places as well
to come up with different architectures
that let you
learn more efficiently in deeper
networks and the commonest way to do
that
is to add more direct connections that
allow the gradient to flow um so the big
thing and vision in the last few years
has been resnets where the res stands
for residual connections and so the way
they're made this
picture is upside down so the input is
at the top um
is that you
have these sort of two paths that are
summed together one path is just an
identity path and the other one goes
through some neural network layers and
so therefore its default behavior is
just to preserve the input um
which might sound a little bit like what
we just saw for lstms um there are other
methods that then being dense nets where
you add skip connections forward to
every laser layer
highway nets
were also actually developed by
schmidhuber
and sort of a reminiscent of what was
done with lstms so rather than just
having an identity connection as a
resnet has it introduces an extra gate
so it looks more like an lstm which says
how much to send the input through the
highway
versus how much um to put it through a
neural net layer and those two are then
combined into the output
um
so
essentially
this problem occurs anywhere when you
have a lot of depth in your
layers of neural network
but
it first arose and turns out to be
especially problematic
with recurrent neural networks they're
particularly unstable because of the
fact that you're do you've got this one
weight weight matrix that you're
repeatedly using through the time
sequence
okay
so
we've got we've got a couple of
questions um
more or less about whether you would
ever want to use an rn like a simple rnn
instead of an lstm
how does the lstm learn what to do with
its gates
can you opine on those things
sure
um
so i think basically the answer is um
you should never use a simple rnn these
days you should always use an lstm i
mean you know obviously that depends on
what you're doing if you're wanting to
do some kind of analytical paper or
something you might prefer a simple rnn
and it is the case that you can
actually get decent results with simple
rnns providing you're very careful to
make sure that things aren't exploding
nor vanishing
but you know in practice getting simple
rnns to work and preserve long context
is incredibly difficult where you can
train lstms and they will just work
so really you should always just use an
lstm
now wait the second question was
um i think there's a bit of confusion
about like
whether the gates are learned
differently oh yeah so the gates
the gates are also just learn so if we
go back to these equations
um
you know this is the complete model and
when we're training the model
every one of these parameters so all of
these w u and b's
everything is simultaneously being
trained by backprop
so
that
what you hope and indeed it works is the
model is learning what stuff should i
remember for a long time versus what
stuff should i forget
what things in the input are important
versus what things in the input don't
really matter so it can learn things
like our function words like
don't really matter even though everyone
uses them in english
so you can just not worry about those
so all of this is learned and the models
do actually successfully learn gate
values about what information is useful
to preserve long term versus what
information
is really only useful short term for
predicting the next one or two words
finally
um the uh the gradient improvements due
to the so you said that the addition is
really important between the new cell
candidate and the cell state i don't
think at least a couple of students have
sort of
questioned that so if you want to go
over that again that might be useful
sure
um
so what we would like is an easy way for
memory to be preserved long term
um and
you know
one way which is what resnets use is
just to sort of completely have a direct
path from ct minus one to ct and will
preserve
entirely the history so it's kind of
there's a default action of preserving
um information about the past long term
lstms don't quite do that but they allow
that function to be easy so
you start off with the previous cell
state and you can forget some of it by
the forget gate so you can delete stuff
out of your memory that's a useful
operation
and then while you're going to be able
to update the content of the cell with
this the
the
right operation that occurs in the plus
where depending on the input gate some
parts of what's in the cell will be
added to
but you can think of that adding as
overlaying extra information everything
that was in the cell that wasn't
forgotten is still continuing on to the
next time step
and in particular um when you're doing
the back propagation through time
that there isn't
um
i want to say there isn't a
multiplication between c t and c t minus
one and there's this unfortunate um time
symbol here but remember that's the
hadamard product which is zeroing out
part of it with the forget gate it's not
a multiplication by a matrix
like in the simple rnn
i hope that's good um
okay so there are a couple of other
things that i uh wanted to get through
before the end i guess i'm not going to
have time to do both of them i think so
i'll do the last one probably next time
so these are actually simple and easy
things um
but they complete our picture um
so we i sort of briefly alluded to this
example of sentiment classification
where what we could do is run an rnn
maybe an lstm over a sentence
call this our representation of the
sentence
and
feed it into a soft max classifier to
classify for um
sentiment so what we're actually saying
there is that we can regard the hidden
state as a representation of a word in
context
that
below that we have just a word vector
for terribly but we then
looked at our context and say okay we've
now
created a hidden state representation
for the word terribly in the context of
the movie was and that proves to be a
really useful idea because words have
different meanings in different contexts
but it seems like there's a defect of
what we've done here because
our context only contains information
from the left what about right context
surely it'd also be useful to have the
meaning of terribly
depend on exciting because often words
mean different things based on what
follows them
so you know if you have something like
red wine it means something quite
different from a red light
so how could we deal with that well an
easy way to deal with that would be to
say well if we just want to come up with
a neural encoding of a sentence we could
have a second rnn with completely
separate parameters learned and we could
run it backwards through the sentence
to get a backward representation of each
word and then we can get an overall
representation of each word in context
by just concatenating those two
representations
and now we've got a representation of
terribly that has both left and right
context
so we're simply running a forward rnn
and when i say rnn here
that just means any kind of recurrent
neural network so commonly it'll be an
lstm
and a backward one
and then at each time step we're just
concatenating their representations
um with each of these having separate
weights and so then we regard this
concatenated thing as the hidden state
the contextual representation of a token
at a particular time that we pass
forward
this is so common that people use a
shortcut
to denote that and they'll just draw
this picture with two-sided arrows and
when you see that picture with two-sided
arrows it means that you're running two
um
rnn's one in each direction and then
concatenating their results at each time
step and that's what you're going to use
later in the model
okay but um so
if you're
doing an encoding problem like for
sentiment classification or question
answering
using bi-directional rnns is a great
thing to do
but they're only applicable if you have
access to the entire input sequence
they're not applicable
to language modeling because in a
language model necessarily you have to
generate the next word based on only the
preceding context
but if you do have the entire input
sequence that bi-directionality gives
you greater power and indeed that's been
an idea that people have built on in
subsequent work so um when we get to
transformers in a couple of weeks um
we'll spend plenty of time on the bert
model
where that acronym stands for
bi-directional encoder representations
from transformers so part of what's
important in that model is the
transformer but really a central point
of the paper was to say that you could
build more powerful models using
transformers by again
exploiting
bi-directionality
okay
there's one tiny bit left on rnn's but
i'll sneak it into next class and i'll
call it the end for today and if there
are other things you'd like to ask
questions about
you can find me on nooks again and just
in just a minute
okay so see you again next tuesday